The Trump campaign has now gone full mask
off and has resorted to tweeting mug shots
of black people.
That that's the argument that I'd punch my
mike there.
That's the argument for not.
Voting for Joe Biden, tweeting mug shots of
black people charged with crimes.
These are posts from the verified Twitter
account, Trump War Room. Trump War Room is
an official account run by the Trump 2020
campaign team.
And they have been tweeting images like this
one that we're putting up on the screen for
our video audience of a black man charged
with violent crimes.
Remember, in our system, you are innocent
until proven guilty.
They're very quick to talk about that when
it comes to sexual assault allegations against
people like Donald Trump.
But again, they're highlighting charges against
someone.
Another example that they tweeted out of a
guy named Dunovant Boone.
Also black charged with crimes.
And there's a ton of these that they've been
tweeting out claiming that these are people
that are free, thanks to Biden campaign officials
who donated to pay bail fees.
So this is both No.
One, completely obvious and transparent in
terms of it's just a racist attack to try
to hurt Joe Biden.
And number two, and this is the part that
I hate to admit, but really it's an indictment
of of the people who vote.
This actually might work.
I mean, I don't know, you know, the Trump
War Room Twitter account is not necessarily
the place people are going to for news about
the campaign.
But the idea that they're floating this on
Twitter could lead to Trump talking about
it in more detail.
And these are effectively Willie Horton ads.
Willie Horton ads are still studied and discussed
today if you don't know what they are.
Back in 1988, Massachusetts Governor Michael
Dukakis, who has been a guest on this program
multiple times, was the Democratic nominee
and was running against George H.W. Bush.
And George H.W. Bush started publicizing with
a variety of different so-called Willie Horton
ads, how Michael Dukakis let Willie Horton
out.
And it was the start of this idea of Democrats.
It was more officially codifying the idea
of Democrats are going to release dangerous
black people into society.
You aren't safe.
Vote for the Republican who will actually
keep you safe.
This is the exact same thing that we are seeing
from the Trump campaign.
And when you step back and, you know, they're
tweeting mug shots of black people, I mean,
it's just it's fully brazen at this point
in time.
Trump's continued use of the term China virus,
he's talked about, you know, Cung, flu wuv,
horn flu, all of this stuff back at the beginning
of his campaign.
Mexico is not sending its best.
It's sending rapists and criminals and some
who I'm sure are probably good people or whatever
the exact quote was, playing coy with the
white supremacists who have been activated
and coalesced by his campaign.
We've seen it all time and time again, and
this is essentially the same stuff.
So the real practical question for Biden,
Harris, is how to deal with this.
There I sort of exchanged a few messages with
Democratic strategists about if you were running
the Biden campaign, how do you deal with this?
Because on the one hand, you could say, well,
it might actually be effective to try to expose
and criticize the fact that the Trump campaign
official campaign people are using these sort
of racially tinged Willie Horton type strategies.
But on the other hand, it doesn't really seem
to have work then.
What I mean by that is Trump has been saying
xenophobic stuff and using racist dog whistles
for years.
He did it in 2015, early in his campaign into
2016.
He's done it throughout his presidency and
his approval rating stuck right around the
low 40s.
And what has actually hurt Donald Trump over
the last several months have been three issues.
It's been corona virus handling.
It's been the economic situation as a result
of the corona virus handling.
And Trump's authoritarian reaction to the
George Floyd protests suggesting and actually
sending in National Guard and sort of further
militarizing reactions to protests that are
over police brutality to begin with.
So the, you know, grab him by the You-Know-What
stuff, the going after Trump for the xenophobia.
It really hasn't worked.
So other Democratic strategists I spoke to
said I would ignore it.
I would focus on what is actually hurt Donald
Trump.
And in the event two days ago that Biden and
Harris did, Kamala Harris focused on an unnecessarily
bad economic situation.
Coronavirus hit every country and every country's
economy has suffered.
But it's worse here because of Trump's failed
response.
We know that that actually is mattering to
voters hit Trump on coronavirus, which Harris
did during this first campaign event 48 hours
ago.
That's another approach from Democratic strategists
who are saying the going after Trump for his
crass.
Nature and the language and all that, it's
not really worked.
Focus on what has worked.
I don't know what the Biden Harris team is
going to do about the birther ism, about the
Willie Horton ads and all of this stuff.
But we will follow it and we will see.
On August twenty third, we will be at the
fifteen year anniversary of the show.
Huge milestone for us.
On the one hand, we're heading towards a million
subscribers on YouTube and on the other hand,
we have this amazing milestone that is going
on.
So on August twenty third, we will be sending
out an e-mail to everybody on our mailing
list with a ungodly is really the best way
I could describe it.
Membership discount.
I would love for you to take part.
I would love for you to grab a membership
as we get into this final stretch before the
election.
And in order to be notified on August twenty
third, just get on.
I'm on my mailing list by signing up at David
Pakman dot com.
We'll take a quick break.
We will open up the phone lines.
I have some of your questions I want to answer
a little bit later.
We've got a great bonus show.
It's Friday and we have a fantastic program
for you.